[Music]
yo mama
sorry dr mama how do you think this
year's gonna go for these new students
i'm psyched you're excited for the first
day of school
why is everybody so rich are you ready
for my party saturday night i got dj
khaled's baby
to make you a playlist it's okay timeout
what is up with these kids
in attendance will be the governor of
california
max dad you look amazing and your hair's
fire my dad's also coming i don't care
about your dad spencer
i just care about zach and kelly
we all want these new kids to feel
welcome let's see what happens
can we talk did you just sit backwards
in a chair wow i've never seen anyone do
that in real life
it's not going to work unless we get to
know them you only know how bayside
works for kids like you
hot kids privileged kid privileged kids
bayside to where i finally felt like i
belong this place is magic
damn i love magic hey max actually i
ordered cheese on mine
take a look in your pocket does this
place ever stop being weird
a one two three
the old gang back together again
[Music]
will you go to dinner with me stop
eavesdropping we're not we're the
bayside a cappella group
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah bayside
the man coach when i grow up i want to
be just like you a single childless
adult who parties with kids
you